[Musique]
nous sommes à paris au grand palais en
pleine semaine de la mode ou fashion
week
comme disent les intimes la femme qui
tire la tronche qui me ressemblent
étrangement n'ai que moi même vous
m'avez donc reconnu est démasqué je suis
donc critique de mode
je suis en l'occurrence au défilé chanel
quelques minutes avant la avant le début
du défilé
ma patronne l'époque une femme
absolument délicieuse me prends à part
et me pourris comme du poisson pourri et
me dit comment as tu pu me faire ça se
mettre un manteau aussi hideuse tu fais
honte à la compagnie je veux plus
entendre parler de toi disparaît et
c'est un crime majeur quand on était
habillé comme il faut pendant ce genre
d'événement dépité je vais m'asseoir
dans mon coin je regarde deux côtés je
laisse le show passé que je regarde d'un
oeil fermé
je sors et là une rafale des milliers
d'e-mails de troll de moqueries de
démonter des mémés même des menaces de
viol quelque chose de complètement
ahurissant parce que ce que j'avais
oublié dépité par mon manteau c'est que
j'étais assise juste derrière on les
voit la fille de mick jagger la fille de
johnny depp
pharrell williams cap taille avec
catherine deneuve n'ont pas pas très
loin tous avaient posté la même photo
qui a été vue des millions de fois de
moi qui avais pas réalisé qu'en fait
pour une fois j'étais hyper visible
quelle ironie pour quelqu'un qui passe
son temps à décortiquer l'apparence des
autres alors moi j'ai un master en
gender studies où je me suis intéressé à
la presse de mode la mode est importante
parce que du peu que je vois là dans le
noir personne n'est sorti à poil donc on
a tous un rapport aux vêtements quel
qu'il soit le vêtement c'est à la fois
la carapace et ce à la fois le paraître
c'est à la fois la intime et le social
c'est ce qu'on montre et c'est ce qu'on
cache c'est un discours et un système de
signes qu'on s'en rende compte ou non
et surtout c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important en politique je
sais pas si vous le savez mais
absolument tous les politiciens au monde
ont des coachs de mode
christine lagarde par exemple j'ai
interviewé d'ailleurs sa coach
m'expliquer que c'est très important
pour elle le portait une veste avec des
grandes et paulette façon working girl
les années 80
parce que c'était une façon de dire
physiquement et symboliquement qu'elle
pouvait occuper le même espace qu'un
homme
autre exemple rachida dati elle a refusé
des codes qui découlait du vestiaire
masculin
elle s'habille en amazone elle a repris
des codes quasiment sexuée des
cuissardes d'aidé et talons de 12 pour
montrer une alternative aux costumes
gris du mâle dominant
attention ces codes sont minées le jour
où elle a accouché quelques jours plus
tard on se souvient d'elle qui se
promenaient donc qui calait à l'elysée
pareil dans les mêmes talents sans le
bébé sans la figure de la mère parfaite
et elle s'est fait assassiner
entre grosses guillemets qui prouve donc
que la mode est au temps intime que
sociologique qu'on lit une femme et
qu'on enferme les gens avec les
vêtements et la projection qu'on fait de
nos choix
je sais que je parle très vite pourquoi
je vous dis ça en 2019
parce qu'en 2019 la politique est à la
mode et la mode et politique
ça c'est un défilé de mode fait par le
nashor bright falls au chu où le nra qui
est un défilé de mode adapté aux porcs
de pistolets et en plus les pièces
étaient pas mal celles plus tristes
cette même année donald trump à dépenser
assez créé en fait une ligne digne de de
rockstar de produits dérivés il a vendu
2 millions de casquettes mais qui marque
great games et à ramener 16 millions de
dollars grâce à ça et emmanuel macron à
lui-même sa propre ligne de
merchandising bleu blanc rouge
est-ce que c'est inquiétant est ce que
c'est terrifiant c'est un signe de
l'époque
c'est un signe qui nous montre
qu'aujourd'hui le pouvoir passe par les
interstices et les canaux qu'on n'avait
pas vu à partir du moment où trump et
des sels fine avec kim kardashian
puis après ils discutent ensemble du
sort de pauvre jeune fille emprisonné il
faut pourfendre faire très très
attention à tout ce qu'on a oublié de
regarder le bon côté de la chose c'est
qu'à côté de ça on a eu pour moi le plus
grand moment de la mode
2,2 cette année c'était les gilet jaune
le new york times a décrété que c'était
les sans-culottes d'aujourd'hui parce
qu'en france on a une véritable histoire
de subversion par le vêtement
nous sommes la ville de la haute couture
paris donc tout émane de paris tout
émane de la mode doute émane du chic
mais quelle chic
quel vêtement est considérée vêtements
et quelques vêtements est considérée
mode par tous les militants sont passés
par le vêtement que ce soit les les
cagoules l'epo cera est ce que ce soit
les libérait des blacks pente où les
couronnes de fleurs des feymen on peut
faire glisser le regard et le piéger
j'étais rédactrice en chef de ce
magazine qui s'appelle antidote le
hasard fait bien les choses
c'était la première couverture qu'on a
fait on a essayé donc de faire ce jeu on
a essayé de piéger le regard on a une
presse d'abord outragé à une femme en
burqa mais c'est terrible mais comment
vous avez pu faire ça mais qu'elle s'est
pas tout le monde pas une jeune fille en
boucle à sète une jeune iranienne hyper
branché qui tout en calvin klein et en
haute couture et qui partait en teuf bon
c'est drôle et c'est triste en même
temps parce que par sa couleur de peau
on en a déduit que c'était une femme
soumise
si je l'avais porter moi femme blanche
serait une lecture complètement
différente et ça c'est le point le plus
important de tout de tout ce toc
rappelez vous que la mode ne sera qu'une
infime mais essentiel marge de manoeuvre
à un corps une couleur de peau une
carnation un âge une origine sociale à
laquelle on ne peut rien faire qui sera
sujette à tous les clichés du monde
reprendre possession des vêtements
prendre conscience des codes qu'on
dégage de de l'image qui peut être lu
qu'on peut déconstruire qu'on peut
détricoter c'est le début de penser
l'autre sans clichés et 60 cents clichés
de ne pas laisser le vêtement parler à
sa place mais de enfin pouvoir
s'exprimer de façon silencieuse parce
que c'est bien de communication non
verbale dont il s'agit et ça ça se fera
bouton après bouton fibra bref libre
merci
[Musique]
et
oui